so is my liking or not liking this being
decided by me or by somebody else black
mirror
Bandersnatch first things first I may
have to end up doing a subsequent
follow-up video on this because as of
this recording I have watched it once
sort of if you've already seen it then
you know what I mean by that I'm pretty
sure I have not seen everything that it
has to offer I'm not sure like I I
haven't gone back to watch it yet from
the start so what you're gonna see right
now is a reaction based off my first
going through the experience of this so
this is all about the initial visceral
this I have not had the comprehensive
experience up to this point I and I'm
not gonna have that for a few days my
partner Liz at time of recording and yep
so bonus for you you get two videos
today cuz I didn't want to bump other
stuff too or have this come out later
cuz I'm excited to talk about it but
anyways my partner Liz she's visiting
her family for the holidays and when she
gets back I want to watch this with her
and so I'm not gonna watch it again so I
watch with her and I and she's gonna
make the decisions on that watch so
we'll see what's different and then if
necessary I will watch the third time
just try and see anything that I might
have missed on the two previous goes so
this is just first viewing now if for
some reason you've missed the boat on
exactly what Bandersnatch is and you're
wondering why it should matter
and then I've only seen it once and why
would things change so um last year I
remember hearing for the very first time
that Netflix was looking into attempting
to implement
choose your own adventure style move in
movies where the viewer will actually
make choices that impact the progression
of the story and when I first heard that
that was something that they were
looking into I thought that is the
stupidest friggin thing I have ever
heard in my life
yeah that's not gonna work as a TV show
and I mean it's arguable how well it
even works in the books but you know
books by their nature are meant to be
picked up put down that works TV without
film and TV especially it's meant to be
something it's meant to have forward
momentum I'll you know this whole sort
of oh it goes here and now here but it
could have been that or that like that's
this is not gonna work and that I heard
Black Mirror was gonna do one I went
okay now I actually want to see that
because if anyone's gonna do with any
kind of do the concept any kind of
justice is it gonna be like mirror and
Bandersnatch is the result so plot okay
so it's it's a period piece is set in
the 80s which makes it almost
immediately somewhat evocative of San
Junipero if you know your other black
mirror episodes there are some specific
callbacks or I guess call forwards since
this is set in an earlier time whatever
there are some specific references to
some other black mirror episode I'm not
gonna say what they are because that's a
spoilery and be like fine beast rage
yourselves they're cool when they turn
up so it's following a guy I'm probably
probably gonna end up calling him a kid
but a guy named Stefan who's a young man
I don't know if they say his age I think
he's a teenager but I don't know he
could he could be anywhere from 16 to 19
I would buy any age in that range I mean
heck TV even early twenties maybe but
he's he's a young man he's very into
video games and this is of course 80s
video games so in computer games and
whatnot and he pitches a concept for an
adventure game that would be
effectively a choose-your-own-adventure
and he's basing it off of this
labyrinthine book which was you know
choose your own adventure book but if
you read choose your own adventure books
when you were in school like I did they
were like yay thick this thing he's
adapting called Bandersnatch is about EA
thick and apparently the guy the guy who
wrote it went nuts so he's trying to
adapt that and he gets the opportunity
to do that and that is the story that we
follow going into any further detail
beyond that is not is kind of
potentially spoilers depending on how
what choices you make and it introduced
that whole thing pretty early on with
what appear to be very arbitrary and
innocuous choices I don't know if they
actually are because I say I haven't
gone back and rewatched so I don't know
if altering those very early choices
does actually significantly change
things I suspect not because it's just
sort of setting up the pattern and the
rhythm of being used to doing that I
think yeah I suspect it's probably
deliberately done with innocuous choices
at the front end and then later on you
are given some what are clearly some
more substantial choices and they are
always choices being made by Stefan by
the lead character but at the same time
he is very much a distinct entity from
you the viewer so whereas in again if
you remember your choose your own
adventure books they were usually
written in second person narration and
the protagonist was actually referred to
as you so it was always for question as
what do you do whereas here Stefan is
very much his own entity and yet his
actions still get dictated by someone
other than himself and as you might
begin to expect from Black Mirror the
show or film or whatever you want to
consider the thing to be starts to toee
with that as it goes along and actually
the
some of the things that it does again I
I don't want to really get into too many
more plot specifics but some of the
things that it does in terms of the way
choices are presented is really
fascinating because there are points
where like you don't actually get a
choice like the choice option will come
up but there's only one and there's a
sudden yo the the point of which I
noticed that you know where that
happened and maybe it happens in more
than one point depending on how on what
choices you make but where I remember
seeing that was just like this thinking
of Oh God
or you know seeing choices that are
effectively the same thing in other
words making it clear that okay you can
make a choice but where this is going
you can't stop where this is gonna go
again at specific points and it does
also recreate from from the choose your
own adventure books that sensation of
like keeping your finger on the previous
page in case the choice you made like
completely screws things up and ends the
story you go back a little ways and so
it does that at a few points to
including some early on I I remember one
of the first major choices I made
basically ended the story we young
within the first 20 minutes and then it
rolled back it gave me the opportunity
to do you know from that point again and
I encountered that a few more times as
it went along and I got to I got to jump
around and actually at one point it gave
me the option to go back to the previous
significant choice that I made or to
just let the credits roll so I think I
like I saw an ending that was like this
could be the ending if you want it to be
I obviously rolled back a bit and kept
going until I ultimately ended up with I
don't know if it will turn out to be
like it the quote-unquote proper ending
of the thing but
there it did eventually get to a point
where like the credits just rolled it
stopped giving me options that didn't
even give me the option to go back again
and the credits just started rolling and
so for this first viewing experience
I'll take that as the ending and again
because black mirror is clever enough
and smart enough it knows how to make
these this silly gimmick integral to
what's going on because it's not just a
gimmick
it's the Matic to the entire story being
told because the character is working on
a project that's about choices that's
about it it's about you know what he's
making is when parallel to what you're
watching and experiencing and as things
start to head in some of the directions
that they can go and the way that
sometimes these choices you feel
deliberately railroaded and that's the
way things kind of have to go because
there is a quote-unquote proper way for
the story to go and it doesn't feel like
the like it's cheating it feels like
it's saying something with that this is
one of the more existential black mirror
projects it it is still technology-based
like much of black mirror is but every
now and then black mirror can get quite
existential in its thinking's it tends
to do that when it what it touches on
the cookies a little bit I remember
thinking that you don't I saw you SS
Callister which was the very first black
mirror episode I ever saw you know the
existential quandary of what it is you
see that this I think this is the show's
hardest dive into existential questions
and it handles them pretty well I'm not
sure I could say that it comes to a
definitive conclusion but given the
nature of the narrative I'm not sure it
should
it was evocative of a number of things I
actually found myself thinking of Donnie
Darko as I was sort of in the
homestretch of the thing which and and
like thinking of that comparison in a
positive way which is odd because I
don't actually liked honey Darko
remember Benny was one of the most
overhyped things I've ever seen
but it did sort of feel somewhat
evocative of that in terms of tone and
some of the ideas just at least in my
opinion done way way way way way better
and yeah this is this is oh and here's
another that I don't I don't know if
anyone else had this happen
and this was this was weird and cool and
like threw me off right at the get-go so
I don't know if it's because I have
black mirror on you know my list of
young things that you know you know the
on the Netflix of my list I have black
mirror on there so as soon as I logged
into my account on Netflix
Bandersnatch immediately started up it
didn't wait for me to choose it it just
started which was weird and perfect and
yeah I haven't looked at reviews or
anything yet so I don't know if that'll
be mentioned by anyone else or if it
happened to other people but yeah that
was uh that was an interesting touch
this thing is an experience and I mean
if you know you like black bear you've
probably already seen it by the time
yeah you're listening to me but I'm not
sure I could recommend it as like a
first go at black mirror I think you
need to have your footing under you know
be on firm ground in terms of what black
mirror tends to be before you try and
watch this but it's it's an experience
and it's the kind of thing that I'm not
sure is ever gonna work again
because this level of immersion into the
concept so that it's not a gimmick the
the thing is that's what you need to do
to have it work any decently but I don't
know if you could tell too many other
kinds of stories other than this one I
don't mean like narrative plot I mean
the matically I'm not sure you can tell
any other kind of story with this
gimmick that elevates beyond the gimmick
so as far as I'm concerned they may have
put the entire concept to bed in one
shot yeah I I don't even know how I like
if I ever do a ranking of all the black
mare episodes again I don't even know
where I'd begin to put this it's good
though in its it's fascinating and ya
see it do it whatever you consider the
experience of this thing to be go do
that Bandersnatch what did you think
about it oh you know I'm you know what
I'll do one I'll add one other thing
here just for a point of reference so
spoilers legitimate spoilers okay so the
point at which the credits just started
rolling for me at the very end was after
Stefan had gone back and found the
rabbit which first of all was a little
bit of a for me because my stuffed
animal my favorite stuffed animal
growing up was a rabbit didn't look like
his but like that was a little bit like
Oh God and Young Money
he gets that as his young self and he
goes with his mother and
on the train that derailed and the
grown-up Stefan just dies in you know
the middle of a of a therapy session and
that was the point at which the credit
started rolling and I don't know if that
is the definitive ending or like the
intended ending because like I said I
have I haven't gone back and seeing what
else there is yet and I haven't like
looked up a wiki and I won't not tell
you to watch it again with Liz and that
won't be for a few days so I may I may
actively be avoiding the comment section
on this on this video but that that was
where the the credits are going and I
felt like that's as close to a happy
ending as this story was gonna get isn't
it he died as a child that's the happy
ending and that's black mirror for you
okay we'll wrap it up there what did you
think about this thing whatever you
thought drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it like I said
I probably won't look at the comment
section on this video until I've seen it
at least another full time through but
all other bunch of stuff you can do down
there cuz there's buttons and there's
links you can make choices about
clicking on them possibly even going to
the patreon and supporting me you will
have choices as to what level you want
to support me I'll stop banging that
that sort of gimmick of the choices
thing but there's other links down there
as well you can check them out if you
feel like it if you don't that's fine
too because at the end of the day folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings assuming that nobody is making
my decisions for me and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]